non-minimalists
i am a very motivated person however
even though i have some interesting
business ideas that would benefit my
career in dancing
i cannot get the motivation to just do
it
instead of planning it what motivates
you to work especially if you're
passionate about it
well my short answer is passion is one
half love and one half
obsession um and really what i mean by
that is
i i think of writing like if people ask
me like
what is your passion for me like that
that is the the thing that i'm most
passionate about is writing
but it is true drudgery most of the time
i teach writing class
now and and one the one of the things i
try to convey is
when you first start writing it's 90
drudgery 10
sort of payoff and that changes over
time it's 80 20 70 30 eventually i think
you get to a point where it's about 50
50. but even now
even though i write pretty much every
day it's still 50 50. there are good
days and there are bad days
and the bad days i still want to put my
head through the wall but on the good
days i'm thankful for those bad days
some of the best writing days aren't
days where i wrote 2 000 words or 5
000 words there are days when i wrote
negative 4 000 words and i just did a
lot of editing and deleting
but i couldn't have done that without
all the drudgery of just getting the
the composition side of things getting
it onto the paper
right and so uh for me i i love
doing it but i also i love the result
but but i also
i get obsessed about it i'm willing to
dive deep and obsession
is about going deep on something for
long sustained periods of time
uh the other pithy answer i have here is
perspiration trump's aspiration
that was my problem for a long time i
was an aspiring writer
but i just aspired all over myself and
didn't didn't do any of the work
right and so so i i would say it sounds
to me like natalie needs to find the the
leverage to obsess
over it uh i mentioned derek silvers a
moment ago and he basically in his book
talks about the the value of ideas being
low but the value of action being
really high and the last thing i'll say
is is accountability partners or just
having people in your life will help
hold you accountable i woke up this
morning really tired
and it was just me recording this
podcast i would have cancelled it on
myself
but i have other people who i'm
accountable to right tk's gonna be here
ryan's gonna be here sean's gonna be
here
reschedule with all of them and ryan's
leaving tomorrow
i know like okay i need to show up and
do this and having someone here to help
hold me accountable
is is helpful all right my pithy answer
is
an idea is worth nothing without action
and
tk i did not know that the root of
passion
uh it was to suffer and when we say
let's hope i'm right about that
you absolutely are so let's let's say
i mean that has literally changed how i
look how i look at the word passion now
because when someone says i'm really
passionate about x
well now i'm going to ask well what kind
of suffering have you been through
yeah so to make to make that happen when
you say i'm passionate about something
i'm willing to suffer for
i'm willing to suffer through the
drudgery of writing to have written
so so natalie you know when i when i
look at her question what i really hear
her saying is
i love the daydream i really love the
daydream some really big ideas
and i just don't have the motivation to
uh
to do it and again an idea without
action
is nothing but the question is is
natalie
what are you willing to suffer through
to make those ideas uh come to fruition
um sitting around and daydreaming uh we
all do that we all love to do that
man like i know i'll get a really good
idea and i'll call josh oh man i got
this really really good idea
and um i haven't done this in a while
but i used to do this a lot and josh
would be like
okay great um uh let's look at what we
have on our plate right now
how are we going to be able to fit this
into what we already have and when i
started looking at it that way well i
call you less and less now
because i know that an idea without
action is is nothing
yeah so so i guess you know the the
advice i want to give to natalie is
you find that leverage that at least
helps you take
that first step if there isn't a barrier
in the way i mean if it's
fear of success or whatever it may be i
mean i think it's important to
recognize those fears but she has to
find some sort of leverage to
at least take the the first step towards
bringing one of these ideas uh to
fruition
yeah yeah i i think that's the key so my
take on this
is if you're passionate about something
and you can't motivate yourself to take
that first step
then your first step is probably too big
and you need to reduce the size of that
um
passion is a very interesting thing
because when we say we're passionate
about something
that concept tends to be bundled up with
other assumptions about
how a person would behave if they were
truly passionate
so for instance you hear people say
things like well i think i love writing
but
i guess if i really loved it i would
write every day and since i don't
actually write every day i guess i don't
love it
right or i think i love running but i
mean you know people who really love it
they run five miles a day and i haven't
ran all week so
therefore even though my heart is
telling me that i love it i will
logically deduce the conclusion that i
must not love
what my heart is telling me that i love
and so we get confused right because we
have assumptions
about what a passionate person would do
and then we have like the visceral
experience of being passionate those two
things are bundled
and it muddies our thinking about it and
you gotta sort those two things out you
gotta say okay wait a minute
if i'm passionate about something and i
can't motivate myself to
act on it then that probably means
whatever my version of acting on it is
is bundled up with these assumptions
that need to be discarded
so if you're passionate about running
and you can't motivate yourself to run
then ask yourself well what does running
look like right now
you know and and that may be well
running five miles a day right
you know like you know running it's like
okay so back away from that
and make it ridiculously easy to start
yeah how does it feel to run for one
block a day
well that seems like something i can do
get out there and do that but you know
what stops us from doing that the two
greatest motivation killers
obligation and guilt you're motivated to
do something already but then obligation
comes in on one side and say it says
yeah but if you were really motivated
you would do it ten times more
and then guilt comes in and says yeah i
know you say you're motivated but you
only did a little bit and your passion
is worthy of so much more and therefore
your passion isn't really there and you
got to kill those things so an example
in my own life
i'm passionate about reading i love it
more than anything else but i went for
about six months of my life not reading
because i was just so busy and i didn't
have time to read books and you know
what the
the breakthrough was for me is when i
said you know what
i'm just gonna read one blog post a day
and i'm gonna commit to that no matter
what and you know what
not only have i read every day but i've
had many days where i felt like crying
because i feel like i am insulting this
thing i love
because i'm only reading i'm not a real
reader i don't love
reading because if i did i would make
time like all of those people who write
articles about how warren buffett read
17 books a week
right and that's how we kill ourselves
with it man but but you got to make it
ridiculously easy to start
and be loyal to your passion in the way
that you can be get rid of the
obligation and the guilt
god dude that is so good well it makes
me think of that rachel cruz book that
i'm going through right now you know
love your life not theirs yeah and um
she just does a great job in the first
chapter of just showing how comparisons
will kill us
it will it will really take away from
our life if we sit there and try to
compare ourselves to yeah we want to be
a writer
so uh let's look at how my favorite
writer
writes and what they've done oh i'm not
anywhere near that so i guess i'll never
be a writer like
yeah it could be debilitating because
it's like you're my favorite writer is
david foster wallace but i also know
i'll never write infinite jest
um and if that was my my expectation
then it would just we'll just give up
right now in fact
most people can't even read infinite
just let alone write the book right
but instead if i say wow if my standard
if i
maybe i can one day craft a sentence
that is like david foster wallace and
then i and i try to do that
you mean a 400 word sentence no i mean
that's also true i mean i have there's
an 835
word sentence and everything that
remains um but
that that was also intentional right it
was a shift in the book and like it's
supposed to be this out loud thing but
anyway
um uh i'm getting too far away from that
but basically what i realized like
there are these there's there's this
beauty yes and i don't have to have
the the the expectation i'm gonna write
infinite jess but maybe i can write a
sentence that
that is beautiful i love that man i mean
even thinking about
uh like hemingway who's a great writer
yeah what is it uh
little shoes for sale never worn like
the shortest story
baby shoes for sale number one right so
even that is something so simple which
is genius it's like you can just take
that little bit and be like all right
can i make a six word story right that
is you know just as just starting with
something really really small
yeah constraints breed creativity yeah
we're talking about adding some
constraints i mean i think hemingway was
radically overrated but
yeah i'm just saying that podcast shots
here
josh just loves the ruffle feathers no i
actually i don't think that at all i
think jimmy was a very talented uh
author and writer and i just like i i
i like messing with the people i care
about most um
for the person who asked that question
uh yeah the uh nathalie i believe was
her name
i kept saying natalie but it's nathalie
oh i thought it was just a weird
spelling for natalie it could be uh
either way natalie or natalie um
one thing before tk finishes up this
question so we can move on
my micro speed uh uh um
simple triggers is an essay i wrote
we'll put a link to on the website i do
60 pull-ups minimum every single day
and the only reason i do that is not
because
i have a goal every day to do 60
pull-ups because
to me that's daunting even now i think
about i'm like and i even though i do it
every day i'm like
to do 60 pull-ups or run five miles
whatever it might be that's not that
sounds daunting but i know that i walk
up below my the door between my bedroom
and my bathroom at least 10 times and
every time i walk below there i do
six pull-ups and before i go to the
bathroom with six quick pull-ups i'm
done
i walk back out six pull-ups and i i do
that minimum ten times a day and
quite often it's a lot more than that
right and so and if not just drink more
water and force me go to the bathroom
more frequently
and i have these simple triggers so so
maybe the the other answer for nathalie
here is
is what are your triggers like you want
to do these things you say you're very
motivated
but but what are the triggers that are
going to take that motivation and turn
it into action